et si la bonne heure c'était aussi
simple que cela dany olivier
pisciculteurs de son état a beau devoir
nourrir quatre tonnes de truites tous
les matins dès 6 heures il a beau s'être
cassé la clavicule il n'a encore rien
préparé pour le réveillon et il l'a fait
exprès que du fric du fric du fret
donc les gens à une commande du river
vous inquiétez pas les truites elles
sont encore dans l'eau avant mais c'est
bien comme ça on le sait ce que j'ai
déclaré lysiane automatique même le
confinement vu d'ici prend une autre
dimension avec ses cages où les truites
ne déprime pas est tout petit mais ça va
pas durer longtemps
c'est un crime que vides là elles sont
là pour la nuit donc elle peut bien
rester une nuit tranquille quand on est
dans une chambre d'hôtel la nuit non
justement elles ont plein de place c'est
ça nous on a très peu de kg 2
le poisson pour m² de bassin le secret
c'est de tout faire à l'ancien black
avons sur les poisons donc alors qu'il y
fume et qu'il y fume et lang d'oiseau du
fumer nous on veut vraiment artisanale
c'est à dire à la fumée de chêne fumoir
à froid juste salé comme pour un hareng
de luxe sur les onze marchés que
visitent la famille comme ici ce matin à
montargis les clients ne s'y trompent
pas et les premiers on est d'admettre
mercredi c'est lé 1er juin toutes les
semaines c'est que c'est très bon et en
plus le bonheur est fort sympathique
donc on sait que du bonheur pas du tout
non c'est pas du tout la même chose a
dit rien comme quoi le loiret a tout ce
qu'il faut pour de superbes tableaux de